Hello, welcome to my garden.
Slash bathroom.
Being a man of the slow mo profession,
I like the film "Inception",
it's a great film.
It's good, love it.
There are some great slow motion moments,
one of them being the kick,
involving the chair, the tips,
the sleeper backwards
into the bath of water.
Gives them like the falling back sensation
you get in a dream when
your stomach drops.
Yeah.
Got this bathtub, we're
gonna put this chair here.
and we've got another
really old tiny chair
I'm gonna sit in, lean back,
and hopefully not injure myself too badly
when I fall into this.
And then we got the Phantom
running at 1600 frames a second.
I fall straight here,
or else I'm gonna die.
Yeah, we'll line you up.
All right, you ready to do it?
So we've bagged the camera,
with a state of the art Tesco bag.
And, we're almost ready.
How was it?
That was commitment!
How do you feel about that then?
Wasn't as unpleasant as I
thought it was gonna be,
but yeah, it was actually quite cool.
Yeah, it looked awesome!
It was that, whoa!
It looked good, it looked good.
It was fun, it was fun.
It was a good video.
Kinda scary, but, you gonna give it a go?
Well I don't have any
clothes to dive into,
don't have a change of clothes,
I don't live here.
All right, it's okay.
I've got a change of clothes.
Well, we've already got
shots of you doing it.
Bit of a pussy, then?
Give the clothes immediately, right now.
How do I look?
Yeah, beautiful.
Loving the trousers as
well, very fashionable.
Bloody terrifying!
What am I doing?
How was that?
It was cold!
Yeah?
I mean really cold!
How was it?
Yeah, beautiful, looked good.
How'd it look?
Yeah, beautiful.
Well, that was bloody fun!
Yeah, it's good.
And pretty much exactly
like "Inception", right?
No, we're in a garden.
We are in a garden.
I am not sure I'd like
to be woken up like that
if I was asleep, though.
No, no, I guess not.
It would be quite shocking.
Yeah, where am I?
All right, well good luck over there,
and I'll just-